(はじめ)ようこそ！ようこそ静岡へ
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗ　ウーッ
どうもHIKAKINです
はい　というわけでHIKAKINさんに
今日は来ていただいてるんですけども〜
来ました久々に。
どぉ〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜→
してもやりたいことがありましてですね
親分と。
(はじめ)こちらの商品があるんですよ
(HIKAKIN)こちらの商品ありますね
(HIKAKIN)あのードンキとかで
よく売ってる僕のマスク↗︎
(はじめ)ほぼ実質HIKAKINさんのマスク
みたいなのが売っておりまして
(HIKAKIN)そうなんすよ
(はじめ)僕これ見たとき思ったんですよ
めっちゃ似てるなって思いまして。
ｗｗｗｗ
ご覧ください　この…似よう
そこで私思ってしまったんですよ〜
親分。 (HIKAKIN)はい
少々お待ちください　(HIKAKIN)うんｗ
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗ
(はじめ)ちょっと買ったんすよね〜
(HIKAKIN)うぁぁヤバ！
(はじめ)ハイハイハイ…
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)やべーこれ全国のやつ
全部買ったんじゃね？これｗ
(はじめ)ハイハイハイｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)生産追いつかないくらい
買ってるｗ　やべｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)フフフｗｗ
(はじめ)ハイハイハイｗｗ
(はじめ)ハイハイｗ
(HIKAKIN)やーばぁこれｗ
(はじめ)ハイハイハイ…
(HIKAKIN)やべーｗ
(はじめ)まぁまぁまぁ　ハイハイハイ
(HIKAKIN)わぁ〜〜
(はじめ)何個なんすかねぇ
(HIKAKIN)え　数えてないの？ｗｗｗ
(はじめ)数えてないんすけど〜
(HIKAKIN)どう見ても100個以上あるよｗ
(はじめ)あの〜ここ1ヶ月で
全力を尽くして→
集めることができる限りの
HIKAKINマスクを集めましたっ
(HIKAKIN)あっそういうこと？
(はじめ)多分100個以上ありますね
(HIKAKIN)だよね
というわけで　なぜこんだけたくさん
準備したかと言いますと↗︎
ってことはですよ親分。
よーく考えてみてください
このたくさんのHIKAKINマスクを
部屋中にこう…置きまくって　(H)ｗｗ
そん中にHIKAKINさんが隠れていても…
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗｗ
絶対ばれないと思うんですよ
で　今　実は奥に畑のメンバーが
みんないるんで→
ダーゲットをあいつらにして
はたして大量のHIKAKINマスクの中に→
HIKAKINさんがいたら
ばれるのかばれないのか→
検証していきたいと思います
(HIKAKIN)なるほどｗ
(HIKAKIN)俺がいるところも大事じゃん
(はじめ)そうなんですよ
(HIKAKIN)いかにこう…紛れるか。
(はじめ)はい
(はじめ)よろしくお願いします
(HIKAKIN)よろしくお願いします　イェア
(はじめ)はい…では早速…
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗｗ
HIKAKINマスクを仕掛けていきましょう…
♪〜
[SE：HIKAKIN「バ〜イ」]
(はじめ)あっ　アーーッ！！
(HIKAKIN)ハハハｗ
♪〜
はいっというわけで大体
仕掛け終わりました〜
ｗｗｗｗ
(はじめ)いやこれスゴイっすよ！
(HIKAKIN)スゴイよ…
(はじめ)待ってください
(HIKAKIN)え？
(はじめ)今もいるかわかんないっす
(HIKAKIN)ｗｗｗｗ
(はじめ)今も…今も…え！
(はじめ)ほんとにほんとに！
ほんとにわかんない　(H)ｗｗｗｗ
(はじめ)え　マジでわかんないすよ！
(HIKAKIN)これじゃあ　いかに体を
隠すかってことだね？　(は)そうですね
(はじめ)というわけで　置いたので
今から親分をどこに隠すかを→
計算していきたいと思います
♪〜
みなさん　お待たせいたしました
完璧にHIKAKINマスクを部屋中に
設置したことにより→
親分の場所が…
とてもわからなくなった気がします
今どこにいるかわかりますでしょうか
♪[シンキングタイム]〜
え　結構わかんないと思うんすよね〜
(はじめ)正解は…ココでございますけど
マジでわかんないっす　これ
♪[HikakinTV ED風]〜
(はじめ)ｗｗｗ
すごすぎます！
というわけで早速…
絶対ばれないような気がするんで！→
早速人を呼んで
検証していきたいと思います
ではいきましょう☆
♪〜
(はじめ)ようへいくん上までお願い
(はじめ)ハァハァハァ
(やふへゐ)なんだなんだなんだァ？
(はじめ)ハァハァ　ヘッ
♪〜
…ッハッハｗ
や…やりましたねぇｗ
やりましたねぇ　これｗ
大量のHIKAKINさんじゃないすか
え　これ本物っすよね？
♪〜
(はじめ)すごくないすか？ｗ
(やふへゐ)すっげぇ…ｗ
♪〜
(やふへゐ)…よう集めましたねｗ
(はじめ)いやほんとにめっちゃ→
駆け回ったんすよこれｗ
(やふへゐ)あー
(やふへゐ)ッハハｗ
(やふへゐ)あぁ… やっぱ…
(やふへゐ)HIKAKINさん跨ぎますね
すんません
(やふへゐ)やっぱこれじゃないすか？
(はじめ)ほんとっすかｗｗ
(やふへゐ)これ…ｗ　The HIKAKINっすよ
(はじめ)それよくないっすかｗｗ
(やふへゐ)えっ？
これ顔違うんすか？さては。
(はじめ)や　多分ほぼ一緒だと
思いますよ
(やふへゐ)スゴイっすねぇ
これはみんなビビりますよ
(はじめ)ほんとにそうなんすよ
(やふへゐ)え゛ぇ゛！！
(はじめ)かかりました…ｗ
(やふへゐ)10万！！
(はじめ)はい…
(やふへゐ)HIKAKINさん…(小声)
えぇ！！
(リピート)
(やふへゐ)えぇぇえ！えええ！ぇ！！
(はじめ)ｗｗｗｗｗ
(やふへゐ)ぇぇ　え　えぇ　ええぇ！！
♪[HikakinTV ED風]〜
(はじめ)本物です…ｗ
(やふへゐ)すっっごい…
(やふへゐ)これはヤバイっすねぇ！
(はじめ)HIKAKINマスクの中にHIKAKIN
さんがいるとばれない説でございました
♪〜
(はじめ)たなっち〜？
(たなっち)はい
(はじめ)ちょっと上来て　上。
(はじめ)早く早くっ　早くっ　ハァハァ
(たなっち)ひぃ　はい
(たなっち)なんだなんだ？
ひぃ〜　[ﾊﾞﾝｯ]　いてっ
(たなっち)へっ　へっ　へっ…(息切れ)
(はじめ)どお？ｗ
(たなっち)ワァ…
(はじめ)10万…ｗ
(たなっち)え？
(はじめ)多分10万円以上は積んでますね
(たなっち)うそでしょ！？　(は)ほんとに
(はじめ)お気に入りの顔とか…ないすか？
(たなっち)お気に入りの顔っすか？
(はじめ)うん
(たなっち)うぉお！！
(リピート)
(はじめ)ハッハッハッハｗｗｗ
(たなっち)おぉ…びっくりした…すげぇ！
(はじめ)ハッハッハッハッハｗｗｗ
(たなっち)びっくりした！
(たなっち)すごぉ
(は・H)ｗｗｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)ブンブンハローたなっちぃ
(たなっち)お久しぶりです
(はじめ)すご…ばれなかった！
全然最初いけましたいけました〜
(たなっち)いやすごーい
♪〜
(はじめ)だいちく〜ん？　(だ)はい
(はじめ)ちょっと上来て上　早く早く！
(はじめ)早くっ
♪〜
早くっ
♪(激しめに変調)〜
♪〜
こわ〜！
(はじめ)どうすか〜？
(だいち)うん…もう…
♪〜
(はじめ)◎△＄♪×？
(だいち)おぉ？
あ　あ゛ぁぁぁあHIKAKINさん！！！！
(はじめ)ハハハハｗｗｗｗ
(だいち)すいませんHIKAKINさん！！！！
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
♪[HikakinTV ED風]〜
[通常ED]
(HIKAKIN)聞いちゃったからなぁｗ
これはカットできないｗ
(は・だ)ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)フフフフフｗｗｗｗ
(HIKAKIN)まぁこんだけいっぱいいたら
気持ち悪いんだけどｗ
(だいち)全然気づかんかったぁ〜